[Music]
the 2010's have been a decade that seen
a huge shift in the landscape of the
anime world that it'd be a shame not to
go through it again I don't to bore you
with a history lesson so let's do this
the good old Vinny Tubeway for me these
are some of the moments in anime that
have carved themselves into the minds of
fans all over the world well what are
you waiting for
let's get the show going
the curtains open and we look at the
first entry on the list mic guy opening
the 8th gate now we've been through this
a lot on the channel so I won't recap it
again regardless isn't it just a
testament of how big this moment was
especially for Naruto long time and the
guy in comedy mentor might guy finally
shows off what he's got in his highly
risky attempt at defeating mother--i in
a way I'd argue that this moment is
probably not the most epic or thrilling
part of the long ninja war saga in
Naruto's final act but think about it
did you even see this coming I mean we
all know from the beginning that Naruto
and Sasuke were bound to have a final
showdown or that the supposedly
smotherer would have his moments of
steam rolling through the opposition but
did we expect might guy out of all
people to be the one to force the
seemingly invincible og ha on the
defensive is certainly a twist that
cemented itself as one of the pivotal
moments of the final Naruto arc
[Music]
I don't rotate are the looseness
comments in a home run on sue Carol
felony
[Music]
few sacrifices and deaths can match the
sheer audacity and glory of the one
shown by rider before Babylonia is
Leonidas there was one big bro character
in a feint series anime remember him of
course you do who doesn't know bro
Skanda yep I'm talking about fate zeroes
ride up it's poetic that the legendary
Greek conqueror gets one of the most
epic curtain calls in fate anime history
opening with the dazzling display of his
noble phantasm and his resounding words
to his master riders hopeless battle
against Gilgamesh truly showed what the
heart of a hero is like he knew he was
heading into certain death yet rider
charged on and faced it with glory and
dignity sheer willpower pushed him to
even nearly get a hit on Gilgamesh he
may not have won this fight but he got
the respect of the king of heroes as
well as millions of faith fans worldwide
[Music]
after 12 emotional rollercoaster
episodes Madoka Magica concluded with a
wish that changed everything
however instead of material things or
miracles Madoka thought of the
impossible transcending into godhood
with one wish Madoka transcends her
mortality into the very concept of
eradicating witches the product of the
despair in the hearts of magical girls
Madoka Magica z' anime series ends with
her taking on the burden of the world's
despair in order to shine an empowering
light that encourages everyone to face
life head-on indeed for a lot more anime
fans at the time 2011 would be known as
the Year Madoka died for our sins
fittingly parallel to the real-life
situation in Japan with all the natural
disasters Madoka Magica was a show that
demonstrated how hope has the power to
overcome even the greatest despair
brought about by fate
[Music]
[Music]
haikyuu solidified itself as the next
big thing in sports anime it has its
fair share of exciting moments and even
the season 3 finale match against
shiritori saw was no exception holding
on to a slight lead and feeling worn
down by the intense joule karasuno
prepared to give their all in a last
shot to win the game utilizing a sync
strategy full of decoys Hinata and
Kageyama set up the decisive spikes talk
about teamwork and it was an extremely
close win to the ball barely went
through Sheela thorez awah and it was a
moment that led to multiple sighs of
relief all over the haikyuu fandom kudos
for an excellent match between the two
teams and an awesome finale you know
what this means I don't you
kurosu knows headed to the Nationals
what awaits them as they take on greater
challenges watch season 4 to find out
acting more Hancock of all night do you
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
since you love rage moments how about
one to symbolize the decade this next
moments courtesy of everyone's favorite
state Alchemist Roy Mustang I don't know
about you but if there's a character for
me that symbolizes being a cool badass
in MMA it's got to be void between his
numerous creative sets in battles and
impressive victories I'm not sure if
anyone save a few select characters
could match this fire wielder angry
Roy's a sight to behold and nothing be
seeing Envy being completely outclassed
his battle with envy much like the one
with lust isn't a fight but a massacre
Mustang gives into all hatred and
revenge inside him at this point he
didn't just want to kill every but give
him a slow painful execution It was as
if he was a completely different
character compared to the one we know
and love the difference between the
homunculus and the alchemist is far too
great and I'd call this one of the most
complete dominations in the series makes
me wonder what would have happened if
Mustang somehow got hold of a
philosopher's stone trust me it wouldn't
be pretty
[Music]
it still hurts to this day doesn't it an
effort worth an entire arc gone to waste
as Luffy's forced to watch his beloved
brother die in front of his eyes hope
turns to despair at the end of Luffy and
aces fight through the Marines stepping
in at the last moment ace takes a hit
from a canoe saving his brother in the
process instead of escaping ace decides
to make the ultimate sacrifice we could
say that a sty on his own terms but that
still doesn't make this moment any less
depressing for the millions of won peace
fans all over the globe reality ensues
and not all rescue missions go the way
the heroes plan Luffy gets slapped with
a dose of reality making him realize the
scale of the world beyond and how he
must keep getting stronger for his
brothers legacy whatever
umeri ditched him yo guitar ha
so yeah way it's the media I know there
are a lot of people who aren't a fan of
the berserk movies but I personally feel
the third berserk movie did a fantastic
job adapting one of the most iconic
scenes in manga an exceedingly rare
event which signifies the birth of a new
member of the God Hand the Eclipse is
the highlight of berserks Golden Age
storyline broken by his defeat and
previous failures Griffith becomes an
easy victim of the god hands it's far
too easy for a broken and proud light to
give in to the greatest temptations of
all a massacre follows with guts and
Casca the only survivors subjected to
visions of his past
Griffith begins his transcendence
culminating with his birth as femto it's
at the intervention of the skull might
to save the black swordsman from
impending tomb it's a fittingly ominous
site to herald the rise of the Lord of
Darkness
what Emily
[Music]
one of the top rage moments this decade
goes to hunter hunters Gordon we're
talking about his key moment in the
Chimaera ant arc where he finally
conceived the typical standards of ideal
heroism and begins his brief
transformation into that thing throwing
all care into the air and looking to
only destroy the otherwise jolly and
upbeat gon transforms and lays pitot
down with a beating that Hunter Hunter
fans won't forget anytime soon the
battle versus PETA is not the most
spectacular fight in Hunter hunter but
that's mostly the point it's not about
putting on a show instead the fight
serves as a combination of God's
character development showing the hidden
depths of what the otherwise cheerful
hero's capable of for a moment it seems
as if the villain and the hero traded
places with gone looking like a complete
and unstoppable engine of destruction
chorus
[Music]
she's just a sadist did you know if you
immediately guess that this featured
moment is Reiner and Burt olds betrayal
congratulation who would have thought
that two of the most iconic Titans one
who's even the face of the series would
turn out to be among humanity's last
lines of defense it hurt especially for
Aaron who's been a little brother figure
to Reiner of sorts to see that the
people he looked up to transform into
the gigantic monsters that have haunted
him right before his very eyes the
moment pretty much came out of nowhere
but it's big enough that it's complete
game changer in the world of attack on
Titan yet we know people can transform
into Titan that this reveal was still on
another level all along humanity's
enemies have been hiding among them and
this scene brought a huge impact and
reactions from viewers to have one of
the biggest mysteries of the show
revealed in such a completely unnerving
manner was amazing and absolutely genius
making all the questions and confusion
fade into the background of the epic
fight that takes place
so did I miss anything of course I did
ten moments isn't enough to list all the
epicness that's been an anime in the
past decade regardless though I hope the
video allowed you to have a more
retrospective look at the past ten years
and relive some of the most exciting
moments in anime 100% sure that you have
some other moments in your mind and I'd
love to hear from you the comments
section is all yours and if you're
interested in more content like this
don't hesitate to hit those like and
subscribe buttons below so that's got to
do it for now but this isn't the end of
Vinnie tube's decade playback see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]